i feel like you've you've definitely
probably answered who are your favorite
um
producers of all time i want to know who
do you think
is the most slept on two or three
producers ever
two or three producers you mean like two
or three producers that
you think deserve to be in more
conversations because i do think
there are a lot that are you know i
think large professors are one of them i
think there's a lot but like
who do you got in that in that in that
list black milk
black milk is so cold black milk needs
more props
you know what i'm saying he's dope you
know what i'm saying so dope
and i don't know if people up on on
vitamin d but he dope too
oh my goodness he's a he's one of my new
favorite dudes
yeah yeah derringer's dope
the griselda guy he's he's great i think
like
yeah danger gets it in you know what i'm
saying but i'm i was an alchemist fan
you know what i'm saying of course aoc
man
yeah yep alchemist and um
you know everyone else i'm a fan of all
producers it's
it's not a fan like 9th one everybody i
like everyone
you know what i'm saying is there um hey
i'm going to say dilla
and mad lib are my two favorites yo
how crazy were both of those mad lib
projects with fred
wow stupidity come on man be having
joints man i heard ma i heard he made a
lot of bandana on an ipad
which is crazy he's played me so many
joints
and sent me so much stuff we talk almost
every other day
and then you know when i tell people
that you're like i can't get them on the
phone for nothing
i can't find them